so this is debugging and profiling
dotnet core apps on Linux very very
specific but then on the other hand not
a lot of people are doing this yet and
not a lot of people know how to do this
yet a lot of this is still changing and
influx and hopefully the tools you'll
learn about today will still work in
three months when you actually have to
do this in production but I have been
following this pretty closely and it
looks like there is there is a story
shaping up so hopefully you'll be able
to hear that story my name is Sasha I
work for a training and consulting
company called Sela and a lot of my work
is this just performance investigations
Diagnostics debugging crashes core dumps
on various systems sometimes I do have
to go back in time like last weeks I was
debugging quote crash dumps of a Visual
Basic 6 application which was not as fun
and then the week after that I could be
debugging Dartmouth core apps on Linux
which is a lot more fun in a way so it's
really crazy that we actually got to get
this far that we are sitting here and
seriously talking about debugging and
production and investigations of dotnet
core on Linux it did take a while and it
was quite a windy journey but we got
there and so some of the things I want
to show you today how to profile your
dotnet core apps running on Linux
without needing a Windows machine in the
background for this we'll talk about
visualizing stack traces of CPU samples
and also of other things using flame
graphs which are a pretty common tool on
Linux and also getting some traction on
Windows as well we'll talk about some
other linux tracing tools like
general-purpose tracing tools which
happen to work with dotnet processes and
they're very important to learn about
because that's the tools Linux people
just use we'll talk about runtime events
that can be collected like exceptions
garbage collections assembly loads all
different kinds of events emitted by the
CLR we can collect and then aggregate
and do some further analysis on and we
will also talk about core dumps and
getting core dumps when our dotnet
application crashes and how to analyze
those scored
using the tools we have in box on Linux
again like it said this is changing
pretty quickly
sometimes monthly sometimes weekly so
again this sort of works and has been
tested with dotnet core 1.1 and that
meant core 2.0 preview and if it doesn't
work next week it's not my fault as much
and some of this is actually built on
top of tools and scripts that I had to
hack together a little to get them to
work but it's all in the slides and
hopefully you should be able to
replicate these results if you actually
need this introduction so just to give a
general overview of the equivalents of
some of the tools we'll see for Linux on
other platforms currently supported by
dotnet core so for CPU sampling for
example for measuring CPU usage on Linux
we have perf that's what we're going to
use mostly on Windows we have a TW event
tracing for Windows and a bunch of tools
on top of that and on Mac OS there are
also equivalents which use the same idea
anyway if not the same infrastructure
similarly tracing which is basically
attaching dynamic login to your system
is something that can be done on other
platforms as well dump generation and
damp analysis also has equivalent tools
we are going to look only on the Linux
side of things in this talk which let me
bring you more demos and more examples
but of course we could do the same talk
on Windows and we could do the same talk
probably for Mac OS and show similar
capabilities anyway it's not exactly the
same tools now before we get started if
you actually intend to use my advice in
production if you intend to use any of
this in your own production system you
have to mind the overhead you have to
know that production monitoring tools
might occasionally have an overhead
which makes them unacceptable for your
purposes so some people here might be ok
if you have like 5% increase in
processing time because you use a
certain tool and other people would say
no 5% is crazy what are you talking
about you're slowing my system down so
you really have to know what the
overhead is and the best way of knowing
is
actually testing it in your own
environment and seeing the effect we'll
touch on the overhead here and there but
otherwise you you are you have been
warned about the overhead and finally
before we get started with the actual
scenarios just to give a bit of
terminology I'll be using sampling tools
and tracing tools in this talk and I
always preface my talks with a general
explanation because this is a little
confusing so basically sampling means
that something is happening so
frequently that you can't record every
single occurrence of that thing so for
example if you wanted to trace CPU
execution
you couldn't possibly trace every single
instruction it would slow your system
down not by 10% but probably by a factor
of 10,000 so the only thing you can do
is sample look not at each individual
instruction but every millionth
instruction for example and then
aggregate those samples to form
something meaningful but some events are
actually low frequency enough that you
can record every single occurs like for
example disk accesses or a loading of
dll's or garbage collections these are
things happening in frequently enough
that you can actually record every
single one and then look at where
they're happening and do some kind of
aggregation so we will use both sampling
and tracing tools in the stock for
different kinds of events essentially
for different kinds of things we want to
trace so here are some of those things
that we might be able to trace and look
into some of these are coming from the
actual dotnet core and the CLR and
the.net framework and some of these are
coming from the underlying operating
system because we are talking again
about window about linux so some
specifics if you have a dotnet core app
your dotnet core app could actually your
own code could actually be instrumented
with some tracing with some performance
instrumentation there is a class in the
dot and framework called eventsource
which you can use on windows to emit etw
events and you can use it on linux to
emit something similar runtime events
which you could log and analyze later
so this is one source of information
event source the CLR itself is
instrumented with a bunch of events both
on Windows and Linux and that includes
garbage collections exceptions assembly
loading just-in-time compilation there's
several dozens of interesting events
that we could trace on the operating
system level between the kernel and user
space there's a lot of libraries loaded
into each dotnet application that we
could also be tracing using Linux
specific tools not dotnet specific tools
anymore in the kernel itself there's a
bunch of instrumentation from the
scheduler to the network layer to the
disk layer a bunch of things that we
could be looking at again OS specific
there's also events like page faults
migrations between processors which are
emitted by the kernel in a slightly
different way but it doesn't matter a
lot for our discussion and finally there
is how were events at the lowest level
which are actually coming from your
processors management unit the
performance management unit and that
includes stuff like cache misses and
branch mispredictions
interesting things they are not actually
OS specific but you do have to use an OS
specific tool to capture them and trace
them in the context of your dotnet
application so let's start with the
official story like how are you supposed
to do this sort of performance
investigation if you look at the
official documentation I'm smiling
because it's funny so the official story
is that you go to a website and you
download a script called perf collect
and it's a pretty long bash script which
was written by a performance engineer on
the CLR team and it's it's fairly
isolated and standalone it's a single
bash script which you can use to install
all the dependencies you'd need for
actually doing performance work on Linux
and perf collect is easy it's really
easy to install all the prerequisites
and then you can collect performance
information on a running system now the
bash script has some command line
options but I'm not covering any of
those and you'll soon understand why
so after you're done with the collection
you have a zip file and then the story
is getting a little murkier you're
supposed to take that zip file and you
can do some analysis locally on Linux
but most of the things you'd want to do
require windows box so you need to copy
the zip file over to a Windows machine
which is sort of surprising I suppose
and then you download per view which is
an awesome free tool by Microsoft but it
only works on Windows and then you use
perfu to open that trace dot zip file
that you recorded and you can do all
your performance analysis there now this
is lovely and it kind of works in most
scenarios even I'd say it works but it's
not something I could live with for my
own production environments first
there's the turnaround time you have to
create the zip file copy it over open it
on another machine and second I actually
like to do my performance work where the
data is where the the system is and just
be amount of time I would have to spend
to set up this sort of environment with
a Windows machine running perfu for me
makes the whole thing pointless so this
is again the official story and it
relies on the same things I am going to
be doing manually but we will actually
be doing the investigation on the same
Linux system without using Windows
specific tools again it's going to be
the same data sources but in a workflow
that hopefully will be a little more
reasonable for actual production
environments so the first thing we will
use for this is a cool tool is a cool
tool called perf this is actually built
as part of the Linux kernel so it's
available for all Linux distributions
it's not always installed out of the box
but it is part of the kernel tree so
worst case you can build it from source
or typically you can install it from
your distributions package manager so
once you have person stalled it can do
both sampling and tracing of various
kinds of events including high-level
ones as well as kernel and hardware
events which are something we'll see a
little later the general architecture of
Perth events of
earth is something like this so on the
left on the kernel side there's the
actual percents component which is a
kernel mechanism that you can attach to
multiple different things happening on
your system to multiple event sources
most of these event sources are in the
kernel as well for example you can
attach it to functions in the kernel you
can attach it to higher-level events
like page folds you can attach it to
low-level how it went like cache misses
there's a variety of different sources
that you can attach that perfects
runtime to but you could also attach to
user space things for example functions
in user space libraries so basically an
arbitrary function in user space can be
traced
using perf and that includes dotnet as
well to some extent
now what perf can do with those events
it advocates is either write them out to
a file just a big file on disk which you
can analyze offline you can analyze it
later or perf can write the data into a
memory mapped buffer and then you can
have some real time components some real
time process looking at the events in
that buffer and just processing them in
real time so if you have very high
frequency events you probably don't want
to dump them out to a file for later
analysis because you'll have huge huge
files so you can instead use the memory
mapped buffer approach you would still
have lots of events to process it could
still probably be quite a high overhead
but at least you're not going to be
writing every single thing to disk all
the time we will also see a little later
some other alternatives available in
modern Linux which make this even more
efficient but this is the general perf
story and this is also what the perf
collect script is using under the covers
so if you don't think about symbols in
advance and this is the first thing we
will have to touch upon then whenever
you use perf and any associated tools
you will get some pretty useless reports
like for example this report over here
is supposed to tell you which functions
in your application are spending lots of
CPU time and
do a demo of this shortly but the report
kind of shows you numbers addresses
right hex numbers and the end
percentages and these are the actual
functions we care about these are the
functions in our own process that should
have names that should have symbolic
names if we're doing this on Windows a
lot of times the tools are taking care
of this for you but the Linux the whole
story is such that you actually have to
think about this yourself so for
different kinds of code there are
different sources of symbolic
information which translates numbers
these hex addresses to function names
that you can actually read and use so
there's different colors here for
different kinds of code here the dark
green is pure managed code which is
just-in-time compiled so this is a plain
c-sharp for example that you didn't do
anything special to it will be compiled
at runtime and for this kind of code
the symbolic information can be emitted
by the CLR into a file at runtime so you
run the application and the CLR prints
out into a separate text file
information about code addresses and
code function names I'll show you what
that file looks like it's a very very
simple format this is by the way
something you have to do in Windows as
well and it uses etw to emit this
information but it's pretty much the
same story if you have dynamically
generated code you need at runtime to
emit information about code addresses
and code function names then you have
the light green over here this is still
managed code but it has been compiled
ahead of time Aoki compiled on windows
engine is the tool you use for ahead of
time compilation on Linux it's cross-gen
and this is a tool that's actually part
of the.net core distribution and you
have to run cross-gen on your target
machine to get symbolic information for
those parts of your application so for
code that's compiled at runtime you can
actually get the runtime to emit
the symbolic information but for code
that was compiled ahead of time you have
to do a separate step in order to get
debugging information and it doesn't
help that the debugging information
question emits is in a format that no
other tool can understand and you need
to write a script to convert it to the
right format but that's let's leave this
behind us so suppose you have symbolic
information for all the managed part of
your application there's still unmanaged
code
there's unmanaged code in the CLR itself
which you would need symbols for and
that's something you can typically get
by either building from source or by
downloading a debug information package
for the CLR and these are available but
not for all distributions so sometimes
you would build from source because
that's just the easiest thing and
finally there's actual operating system
binaries for which you also want
symbolic information and that is usually
easier to get so for the kernel it's
typically available online like part of
the running system is symbolic
information for the kernel and for OS
libraries like the C runtime for example
or the P threads library this is
something you can get as a package with
your distribution and it's so boring but
unfortunately you have to get this right
because if your call stacks if your call
stacks from your managed applications
are broken at any of these layers you
can't do performance profiling you can't
do tracing you can't do any meaningful
work without function names of your code
so this is something you have to
actually get out of the way and first
collect sort of does this for you but
again the result can only be analyzed on
Windows which is pretty useless again
for me what we are going to do with
these stack traces and this is the last
intro part before we actually dive into
the demos what we are going to do with
these stack traces of our application
that we collect is visualize them using
flame graphs and flame graphs are very
useful for displaying a large number of
coal stacks so think about coal stacks
when GCS occur or coal stacks where you
access
miles or coal stacks when you use lots
of CPU you have millions potentially of
different coal stacks that you want to
visualize and display to the user at the
same time this is where flame graphs can
help it is basically a very simple
visualization approach where each
rectangle you see on the diagram is a
function the vertical axis the y axis is
just the stack trace so if a function is
on top of something it was called by
that other function and finally the
horizontal axis is not a time line it's
just sorted alphabetically it's pretty
simple and I'll show you a live example
of a flame graph coming up so with all
the setup and the introduction in the
introductions out of the way we can do
some CPU profiling some of the things
I'm going to show you are going to be
live demos and some are going to be
precooked screenshots but let's see just
how much time we have exactly so here I
have a new bunch of arcs pretty standard
configuration I did not build my own
dotnet core here I use the standard
package of that meth core 2.0 and I have
this buggy application which has a bunch
of different issues and now I think my
SSH connection is kind of dropping
connard's there so I'm going to run this
thing in fetch mode this is just one of
the things this application can do it
basically is supposed any way to fetch
apple.com every once in a while and do
something with it right the code doesn't
really matter but looking at a top for
example you can see that this buggy
process is actually taking like a full
CPU core and then some so it's really
busy on the CPU even though it's just
supposed to be fetching apple.com of the
internet so something is interesting
happening we are going to use a perf to
record the behavior of this application
and then to analyze it before we do that
I want to show you the symbolic
information file which was already
emitted when I ran this command so it's
just part of the execution of the CLR if
we look in the
temp folder I have a bunch of those perf
info map files and a bunch of perf map
files these perf map files are generated
by the CLR and contains embolic
information for that specific process ID
so if we just look at perf pit of buggy
dot map this is the map file for my
process here's what it contains it's a
super simple stupid format code address
code size function name code address
code size function name in text format
plain and simple now this is generated
in order for us to be able to actually
give you function names in profiling
reports this is the only reason this
file is needed so let's go ahead and
record the CPU behavior of this process
I'm going to do a perfect cord
I will ask for stock traces I will
record 997 samples per second because
that's what I like you can configure the
number of samples as you like to control
overhead essentially and I will attach
to the specific process because I'm not
interested in system-wide CPU
information just that specific
application so this is running now and
collecting essentially until I hit
control C or until the process
terminates you'll notice the process
keeps running it's not affected it's not
like you had to restart it to profile
this is perfectly suitable for
production use and perf tells me that
nine thousand eight hundred and forty
seven samples were generated so perf
actually sampled the CPU almost ten
thousand times
and wrote down every single every single
sample with a stack trace now there's
multiple ways we could visualize this
information but the flame graph is
easiest so I'm going to skip a little
head and a couple of demos steps and
just show you a ready-made flame graph
of the same application that I generated
in advance there's multiple ways to
generate flame graphs
the easiest one is using a pro script
which takes in the perf file and just
spits out this beautiful relatively
beautiful diagram so we call that the
wider something is the more prominent it
is this is how you read this thing you
look at the widest things so looking at
the right first because that's not the
whitest thing but it's interesting you
can see some GC code over here so GC one
for example is a function in the garbage
collector in the CLR garbage collector
and you can see from the tooltip it was
responsible in this particular profile
it was responsible for 20% of the CPU
samples so 20% of the time I was
actually doing GC looking at the main
part of the flame graph the widest part
there's functions here like main and
fetch and then process result so maybe
it's not the HTTP requests taking lots
of CPU time but it looks like I have a
function called process result which is
taking 60% of my CPU time and what is it
doing I can zoom in only on that
particular function and its descendants
and then you can see on the Left I have
a lot of string allocations some
allocating lots of large strings and
these are stacks inside the garbage
collector I also have this taking a lot
of time like 40% of my time is mem move
AVX unaligned erm s this is actually a
function that's clearing out memory
that's what it's doing it's placing
zeros in memory so that was also called
a lot because I'm doing lots of
allocations and finally there's also a
little flame over here which I don't
know if it's significant but I could
touch it and then see exactly what's
happening here you'll notice that the
stacks go all the way into the kernel
not just managed code not just CLR code
but all the way into the Linux kernel
with functions like this M protect which
is a Linux system call so we have let me
just unzoom we have a visualization of
the
a this application is spending CPU time
and the flame graph itself is
platform-independent of course you could
generate a flame graph from windows data
from linux data from mac OS data it's
just a visualization method for seeing
where my application is hitting lots of
stack traces of a certain event in that
case the event was CPU usage but you
could generate flame graphs of other
kinds of events as well so we have
determined that this app is as part of
processing results is allocating lots of
memory and there's also lots of garbage
collection going out in the background
so a little later we will come back to
that and try to understand where these
garbage collections are coming from
exactly which types are being allocated
so we'll come back to the memory aspect
of this application so far we just
looked at the CPU part so let's see if I
haven't missed anything
/ / if record these are your screenshots
of the demo I've just shown you and the
flame graph we just looked at so what we
did so far was look at the perf way of
doing things and again just to remind
you we ran perf and then we got a file
perf that data which had almost 10,000
samples CPU samples inside now that's
actually not so bad it's 2 megabytes of
data from I guess about 10 seconds of
running time so I could imagine leaving
this on for like 10 minutes maybe half
an hour getting a few gigabytes of data
then analyzing them it's actually still
kind of sort of feasible but for higher
frequency events like if I try to
collect using perf file accesses or
network events and I had like millions
of events per second the file would be
pretty big pretty unmanageable
I'd say unopenable by any standards - so
this is where an alternative Linux
kernel technology comes in for
collecting performance information this
is not covered by the official tools
like the perfect tool I mentioned
earlier it uses perf exclusively but
once you know what's happening under the
covers
you can obviously use other tools as
well so we're going to use that new
underlying kernel technology called BPF
and I could spend like two hours talking
about BPF itself and where it came from
and what it can do for us but in the
context of dotnet performance
investigations on Linux you should know
that PPF is often an alternative for
getting lower overhead data for getting
lower overhead performance
investigations when the rate of events
is high so if you're tracing a system
with lots of networking and you're
interested in networking events perf
might generate lots and lots of data and
BTF might be a lower overhead or if you
are sampling CPU usage and you have a
large number of cores and you're doing
high frequency sampling you will get get
we will again get huge files and BPF can
be an alternative that generates lots a
lot smaller results so the way BPS
basically works for us as opposed to
perth is that it does the aggregation in
the kernel instead of generating a
perfect data file which we have to then
aggregate in userspace by running some
sort of script what happens with BPF is
that the aggregation is happening in the
kernel so just to explain what I mean by
aggregation very briefly if you have a
million stacks which are all the same I
have a million stacks in the exact same
function spending CPU then if you use
the perfo proach you have to record
every single call stack to the file so
you have a million records with exactly
the same whole stack in your file and
then you can do an aggregation and
userspace this is also how etw and
Windows works this is how most profilers
actually work they record every single
call stack and they do the aggregation
or flying with BPF you do the
aggregation online you do not record
every single call stack you just know
it's the same calls that you've already
seen and you increment the counter okay
so I've seen this call stack a million
times
now I've seen this call stack a million
x plus one that's sort of what you do in
terms of aggregation so BPF based tools
are by default more efficient the
question is if that if this efficiency
is actually important for you like what
the overhead is in the first place so
you can improve it we're not going to be
using bps directly anyway we will be
using a front end a bunch of Python
scripts on top of BPF which is called
DCC this is an open source project with
a lot of contributors from different
places including Facebook and Netflix
and I've written a couple of these tools
also and they are basically wrappers on
top of the underlying kernel features
which are easier to use because it's
just Python scripts that you have to run
with certain parameters and this can be
used for dotnet investigations
absolutely and I'll show you a couple of
examples the only reason why you
wouldn't be using vpf always just by
default is that it requires a fairly
recent kernel it's only supported the
things we'll be doing or only supported
in kernel 4.4 or so which is what you
have in a bunch of 16 Fedora 24 so
recent Linux distributions will have
that but if you try to run these tools
on like CentOS 6 or something you will
need to upgrade your kernel and then
it's a little trickier so here are some
of the tools that open up once you also
start using BCC there's tools here for
low-level stuff like file system and
disk and network and there's also tools
for managed languages for example
there's a tool we could use for dotnet
called UGC which traces garbage
collections whenever there is a garbage
collection it prints out a message and
the time it took so we have tools very
high level for specific run times and
even databases for tracing database
queries and we have tools on the very
lower levels of the system including
even CPU events in the picture so these
are all part of the same package and I
obviously encourage you to try them even
if you're not doing data and core and
Linux but rather something else on Linux
in
so let's see some examples of tracing
I'm going to do some of these are
screenshots just to save us a little
time so what happens here on the left is
that I have my buggy application run in
a slightly different scenario and here
it's just kind of not starting properly
it keeps printing out opening
configuration file opening configuration
file and doesn't make any visible
progress now obviously there's a bunch
of tools we could run now maybe we could
look at the log file but the log file
doesn't say anything like this is the
only information I have opening
configuration file good luck with that
so in this in this kind of case what is
often helpful is to use a workload
characterization tool that would look at
this process and tell you what kinds of
things is it's doing like what kind of
activity is happening so it could be a
high level tool like is this using lots
of CPU yes or no or it could be slightly
more specific and we have a tool called
sis count which is designed for looking
at system calls I can attach it to a
process and it will display all the
system calls this process is making
aggregated by number so I can see in the
output here that this process sorry has
made for open Siskel's and can futex
fiscals
and so on so every system call every
interaction between user and kernel
space is counted now suppose I am
interested specifically in these open
fiscals there is a dedicated tool called
open snoop which we could run to get an
output of all the opens all the files we
are trying to open in that application
which kind of makes sense because we are
keep getting errors about opening a
configuration file and the output just
tells us that yeah well we are trying
repeatedly to open this file called et
Cie buggy conf
and the file does not exist or anyway
there's an error opening the file
because in the file descriptor column I
get -1 so the open call is
actually failing so just by looking at
the process figuring out which system
calls its making and then tracing
specific ones tracing opens we are able
to understand why this process is
failing to initialize and what file it
is looking for and then maybe if I
create that file it's actually going to
start up
now this is not dotnet specific this
could have been done exactly the same
way for a Java app or for a C++ app or
for a Python app so let's switch to
something that's more dotnet specific
and this I'm going to do live so
remember this fetch application it's
actually still running still fetching
Apple comm and burning lots of CPU and
we already know from the flame graph
that we had lots of garbage collections
but from the info we generated
previously so let's switch to actually
figuring out how many so the question I
want to answer now how many garbage
collections is this process having now
on Windows it would actually be pretty
easy like if you search Stack Overflow
you'll probably find ten thousand and
five answers saying you should use
windows performance counters and there's
a windows performance counters called
GC collections under dotnet CLR memory
and you can see this in like five
seconds not so much on Linux and there's
two general approaches we could take one
is going to use runtime events and we'll
come back to that the other option is
just saying okay well this is all
happening inside the CLR the CLR has a
bunch of functions for for GC like a
bunch of C++ functions that do garbage
collections let's just trace those
functions and Linux actually has tools
that enable need to attach to any
arbitrary user space function and trace
its invocation so here's and it's going
to work I'm just going to use a command
I typed in previously and you'll shortly
see why so this is this is the command
I'm going to run so the tool itself is
called func account and it's not
actually a very difficult tool you just
give it a pattern and it will trace all
the functions matching that pattern the
only hard part here is the
us to leave course CLR lib course CLR is
just the main CLR component this is
where the garbage collector lives and
because this is a stand-alone dotnet app
I've used dotnet publish to package it
it doesn't depend on the main shared
dotnet installation anymore it's all
just local and so this is just the file
I can ship with my app and that's what
I'm using so lip course CLR and I'm
interested in all the functions that
have this pattern in them so anything
that has garbage collect inside so I
just have to run it from the right
folder though so let me go to a dotnet
buggy and run it from here
no it's not here it's oh sorry it's over
here no functions matched by parent
garbage collect but seriously oh and the
start at the end
okay so 14 functions actually have a
garbage collect in their name and we are
now live tracing all of them this is
kind of like a debugger but a million
times more efficient and once I hit ctrl
C I get a summary of how many times each
function was invoked now this looks very
scary because these are Mangold C++
function names and you don't see the
actual class name nicely but I could
take this thing and pass it through a
command line tool called CPP filt and
then you see it's actually a pretty
reasonable name it's a function called
garbage collect generation which takes
an integer which is probably the
generation to collect and an enum called
GC reason so this is very similar to the
managed API so now I want to know who is
calling that function in my process like
where are garbage collections being a
cost so for this we could use a
different tool and again I'm just using
a command I previously typed called stat
count and stack count takes very similar
arguments except I give it a very
specific function like trace this
function and tell me who calls that
function
kind of like a debugger but again in a
much more efficient package so if I run
this it's tracing until I hit control-c
and finally here's the interesting part
the output has coal stacks in my
application and the number you see on
the bottom is the number of times this
call stack appeared so three thousand
nine hundred and eighty-eight times that
function was called by the following
call stack now this is all not
interesting this is just C++ code inside
the CLR but it is getting interested it
is getting interesting over here so this
is my app this is process result this is
allocate string now we kind of knew this
already because we cheated and look at
the flame graph before but we now know
where the garbage collections are being
caused and so in lots of the cases
anyway in three thousand nine hundred
and eighty-eight cases in the recording
I've made they're caused by this
particular place in my application this
could be a lot easier like this
definitely could be simplified but
unfortunately currently with the tools
we have for dotnet core on Linux this is
kind of the way things work you have to
mash different tools together and
usually get something functional but at
the cost of having to kind of redevelop
the whole process yourself so I've done
some of the work and I've also
documented some of these things but it
is still a little tricky I'm going to
show you a couple of examples before we
move to dumps for the for the end I want
to show you a couple of examples based
on the actual runtime events that are
part of the CLR so this is moving more
to the official side of things
turns out again that the CLR itself has
events built in for different
interesting things that are happening
garbage collections exceptions assembly
loads JIT compilation a bunch of
different events have in the runtime a
dedicated location that would print a
message essentially where that event
kurz now the way this works in Windows
is using etw event tracing for Windows
Linux doesn't have event tracing for
Windows
so instead Microsoft opted to use LT t
and g LT t and g is linux tracing
toolkit next generation I think it's
basically a library for tracing for
emitting log messages on Linux systems
it's fairly efficient and the general
infrastructure is that there is a kernel
component which can attach to different
events and then emit those to either a
file which can be analyzed later or a
memory buffer that can be analyzed in
real time now if you're getting a deja
vu with the perf slide it's for a good
reason because it's essentially the same
architecture you have a kernel component
which aggregates events and then can
push them to either a file or a live
memory buffer for consumption except
this is what they chose to use instead
of instead of perf there's actually lots
of additional logging frameworks like
this so how do you use this thing and
what can you do first in terms of in
terms of events so we're not going to be
interested in kernel events for this
because we already have perf what we
will be interested in is user space
events which are part of the CLR so you
do need to get a list of the different
events you can attach to this is not
very easy but you can read the source
code so the the core CLR source code on
github has a list of all the different
events so exceptions and GC and JIT
compilation all the things I mentioned
you can take a look at the source and
find them there and then here's what the
workflow actually looks like so I'm
going to do is a screenshot some is a
live demo because there's just a lot of
pointless commands to type so basically
ltte and jean comes with a command-line
helper called
LT TNG which you use the create
recording session to add the interesting
events you care about and then to get
the
profile the actual recording so you can
see here we create a trace session we
add a few context values such as the
process ID and the process name so we
get those as part of the trace as well
we enable all the dotnet runtime events
starting with exception and we also
enable all the dotnet runtime events
starting with GC and then our
applications Fights logging as soon as
we call LTP energy start so this still
happens in parallel with the application
you don't have to restart the
application you don't have to do
anything invasive the app is running and
in the background you run these commands
to get a recording of all these
different events and then finally you
can do stop and destroy to finalize the
recording and let's see what the end
result actually looks like so I'm going
to resize this a lot there's a tool
called babel trace which is one of the
tools for tracing for parsing LTTE and g
recordings and i can point this thing to
my trace file under l TT in G trace as
my trace if I just do that it's going to
print lots and lots of screen full
screens full of events each line here is
a runtime event such as you see here
GC sampled allocation hi this is one of
the events the CLR can emit now this
isn't particularly interesting let's
look for exception events in this output
for example so I'm just going to ask for
the first two these are the first two
exception events in industries so you
see exception thrown the exception
happened in the body process the
exception type was HTTP curl exception I
had the exception message saying
couldn't resolve hostname so it's
actually given me the exception details
as you could see in the exception object
the one thing it's not giving me is the
stack trace which is a pretty valuable
thing for an exception to have
but unfortunately yeah unfortunately
ltte and G out of the box does not
support stack traces so like LD T and G
as a choice for logging framework
assumes you don't want stack traces
which is again kind of weird for
exception events but probably sort of
okay
for most other events you'd want to omit
so let's take a look at something else
instead of exception let's take a look
at GC start events so here are a couple
GC start v2 that's the actual events
name and the details here are actually a
little more cryptic so what is the count
whether the depth what is the reason we
don't really know we'd have to go back
to the source to understand but
obviously we could build tools on top of
this so this is the underlying
infrastructure it's fairly low-level but
we could get a listing of all these
different events and build tools on top
one very very simple example of a tool
that you can build on top is just a
one-liner shell command so what I did
here is I recorded GC allocation events
so basically memory allocations events
from the dotnet process and then I
sorted and the removeduplicates and
counted the number of appearances and so
at the end I get as output the number of
times I allocated objects of a certain
type now this is sampled so it doesn't
represent all my allocations it
represents a sample of my allocations
kind of like CPU sampling but it's again
illustrative of the things that you can
do we could grab all the runtime events
and then we could build processing
pipelines on top of those and I say we
have to build because that's what we
have to do it's not something you get
magically out of the box as part of a
tool you do have to build this on top of
the infrastructure I'm showing you here
it's all a story of how you build your
own performance tools essential so one
final thing I when I talk about and then
if you have any questions is
rhythms and how to analyze crash dumps
core dumps of dotnet applications in the
field this could warrant its own talk
but I'm going to give you the highlights
so first of all just to make sure we all
know a core dump is a snapshot of a
running process so you have a process
running and then maybe it crashes you
want it to be captured to a file so you
can analyze the reason for the crash
later so that's what a core dump is you
come to a running process you suspend it
for a second you save the whole thing to
a file and then the process can keep
running if it actually had an exception
and crashes then it doesn't keep running
but at least you have a snapshot of
where it was when it crashed so this is
the general idea how do you generate
core dumps on Linux this is not dotnet
specific again there's a file that you
set in order to tell the system to
generate core dumps at all and this can
actually be configured to not write out
a file but to run an application where
there's a crash there's a lot of stuff
behind this file but you can tell the
system to generate a core dump in the
process crashes there's a limit on the
maximum core file size which you would
sometimes have to increase because it
sometimes starts at zero which means you
don't get a core dump file and finally
once you do that you will get core dumps
for crashes if you want to generate a
core dump on demand like maybe your
application server is stuck and you want
to see what it's doing then you will
also want the G core tool which comes
with gdb and you can point that to a
process and get a dump file on demand
get a core dump at that instant in time
now what do you actually do with this so
core dumps you can analyze exclusively
using ll DB on Windows you can actually
open crash dumps with Visual Studio but
you cannot take a crash dump from Linux
and open it in Visual Studio this is not
supported so you need to do this on your
Linux system and you need to use
specifically LOD B not gdb because gdb
doesn't have a plug-in for dotnet code
now once you actually open G open L LD
be I'm going to show you what happens so
I have a core dump of a crashing
application I'm going to show you maybe
the crash for a second here this is what
the crash looks like when the
application crashes it's a console app
so it prints out I had an application
exception and I get a call stack I get
the crashing call stack right here now
if you worked with TPL before you might
be able to recognize this this is not
the original crashing stack trace this
is what happens when you run a task in a
different thread and there's an
exception in that task and you didn't
process that exception and then when the
task object is finalized it will throw
an exception for you telling you that
you had an unhandled exception in the
task but not actually giving you the
call stack of that other exception that
happened so this is a pretty nasty
situation but fortunately we had dump
files configured so we had a core dump
for this scenario so here I'm opening
that core dump using ll DB there's
nothing particularly fancy in this
command line this is just the path to my
application and this is the path to the
core dump file so l DB spits out a lot
of output I'm going to clear the screen
now the first thing I want to ask for is
the call stack tell me where we crashed
like what the the exception stack trace
was there's a command for this BT back
trace here's what it says so like this
is this is fun and this is great but
this is my C sharp code we are familiar
with this issue some something needs to
give debugging information for these
addresses we need to translate them to
function names now we might have a purse
map file but ldb cannot use perf add
files perf my files are for perf
elodie be cannot use personnel files so
what we need to do is essentially not
use the underlying debugger but instead
load a plug-in which ships with dotnet
core and that's actually pretty much the
same story in Windows if you use windbg
and Windows to analyze crash dumps you
need the SOS debugger extension which
some of you might have heard about and
used before one Linux it's the same
story you need a plug-in you need the
SOS plugin for ll DB in order to inspect
dotnet questions so the plug-in is just
part of the.net core distribution so
here I am loading it
it's called Lib SOS plug-in Esso and it
also needs to take the path to the to
the CLR for some reason it can't detect
it whatever we've done this got it out
of the way now we get a bunch of
additional commands in the debugger
which are coming from that plugin so one
example of this would be for example the
threads command the threads command
tells me what my manage threads are my
dotnet threads not all my application
threads and it shows me here that my my
first thread this one here in the
exception column it has an application
exception this is the exception we have
already seen we know about this guy
so let's take a look at the exception
object from here SOS has a command
called print exception which takes an
exception object and prints its details
now this is the same as it is in windbg
on Windows which is at least one good
thing about this now as you recall it
prints out a pretty useless call stack
it tells me that you know I had an
unobserved unobserved task exception
this is not the original the original
exception call stack this is just how it
manifested so I need to get like the
inner exception somehow out of this
thing except it's not really there so
we're going to do it slightly
differently I want to switch to that
thread
and look at that threads call stack
maybe we'll figure out something from
the call step so typically what you do
is run the CLR stack command to get a
stack trace but then LD be well the
plug-in complains unable to walk the
stack the current thread is not a
managed thread so if you look at the
threads output again the Linux thread ID
for this thread is 9 5 7 C whereas the
debugger here thinks it's 0 because for
some reason again you have to tell the
plug-in explicitly which Linux thread ID
corresponds to the current thread in the
debugger which is insane because it
already knows this but you need to tell
this anyway so there's a command called
set SOS thread ID which takes the OS
thread ID 9 5 7 c and the debugger
thread ID then ask me why you need to do
this just know that you have to do this
and I wrote a script that actually
automates this but in any case once you
have done that you can actually run CLR
stack and get the managed call stack for
that current thread which is the same
same thing we saw in the exception
message so why am I even doing this
because the publish unobserved task
exception method and also my function
here handle and handled exceptions takes
an event args object which contains the
original exception information so my
plan right now is to glean that original
exception out of there and the way I'm
going to do that is ask for parameters
to be displayed and then you'll see here
it tells me that my function handle
unhandled exception takes an event args
which has this value so at this point
I'm going to ask the debugger to display
this object again these are the same
commands from windows SOS except if you
don't use windows SOS it doesn't help a
lot but it is the same commands and
notice what happens here
the unobserved test exception event args
inside has the original exception now
once we have that we could maybe hope to
see the original exceptions or a print
exception of dump exception we could
hope to see the original exception but
it's an aggregate exception and the TTL
aggregate exception doesn't so easily
give up what the actual exception was so
you need to look at the object instead
let's do SOS dump object out that
aggregate exception object we are
printing this time the aggregate
exception object has a list of inner
exceptions inside so you can take that
list oops
you can take that list and dump that and
inside the list there is an array of
exceptions so now we could dump that
array and in the array there is just one
element there's just one exception we're
hunting for which is here and assuming
it is an exception we will get the
original exception message and it's call
stack so it turns out we actually had an
invalid operation exception in a
background task and this is the source
code in my process which caused that
exception in a background task and that
was wrapped by the aggregate exception
business which was so tricky to figure
out but I wanted to show you an actual
real example of why you would need to
analyze the core dump because the
original exception message was totally
useless and it didn't point to the
actual place in my source where the
exception occurred visual studio would
have done this for you in like three
seconds you would click click click and
you would get to the original exception
object this is slightly more complicated
but this is the only alternative for
Linux this is the only way you can
analyze core dumps of dotnet core
processes on Linux so if I tell you that
the
all diagnostic story is not like 100%
super baked and complete yet I hope you
understand why so let's wrap up I've
this is just a set of screenshots of the
whole walking through objects I've just
shown you so you could replicate this
later
I have a checklist slide here which is
just for your reference that shows all
the things you would need to configure
and set up in order to be able to do
this Diagnostics on your own machine
some of this is needed for performance
investigations some of these is needed
for tracing and some of this is needed
for core dump analysis but if you don't
go through these steps ahead of time you
would not be able to come to a running
button score app and get out all the
information I was able to show you in
the demos so there's actually some
preparation required which I skipped to
make this a little shorter in terms of
what we covered just to make sure we
really saw it all we profiled CPU
behavior in dotnet core applications
using perf and flame graphs we
visualized again the stack traces we got
and so nicely in a in a nice diagram
illustration where our application was
spending lots of time on the CPU
we used Linux tracing tools such as perf
and BCC to look at Dartmouth core
applications and that works I mean no
reason why standard Linux tools wouldn't
work for dotnet core processes we looked
at Dartmouth core run time events like
GCS and exceptions which are emitted
using LTP and G so we have to use the
LTTE ng toolset to look at those and
finally we looked at dump
generation and analysis which requires
ll DB and the SOS plug-in and a bunch of
additional commands that you have to
remember this whole thing is painful and
again there's lots of room for
improvement here I hope to see lots of
changes and Dartmouth core 2.0 but there
weren't any significant changes there's
a lot of work in progress
but if you are currently deploying
doesn't core to production or if you're
planning to you should be advised about
the meaning of doing performance
investigation
on those systems trivial issues would be
trivial and the hard things will be very
very hard because the tools are in this
sort of state I have a bunch of
references for you to look at later
including some of my own blog posts you
can find this whole thing in my slides
and the demo application I've used is up
on github as well so you can replicate
some of these experiments if you would
like if you have any questions if you're
interested in that net core Diagnostics
at all please catch me later I'm out of
time but there's a longer break now I
think so we can absolutely have a chat
if you'd if you'd like and I hope you
enjoy the rest of NDC thank you very
very much for coming thank you
[Applause]